sur le tarmac de l'aéroport d'orly deux
ambulances arrivent ce dimanche à leur
bord deux patients atteints du covin 19
respectivement âgés de 33 ans et 70 ans
ils vont être transférés par voie
aérienne au chu de bordeaux
une opération qui a demandé à cet
hôpital de se préparer alors que le taux
d'occupation de son service de
réanimation atteint 90%
on a libéré des lits et donc des des
patients sont partis vers des secteurs
d'hospitalisation qui sont déjà en
tension on va être amené à commencer de
déprogrammer tout au moins les
interventions lourdes et donc il va y
avoir bien évidemment une pénalisation
pour certains patients qui pourront pas
se faire opérer de gros se change en
tout ce week-end six patients ont été
transférés depuis l'île de france vers
d'autres régions les hôpitaux
franciliens au bord de la saturation ces
évacuations sanitaires permettent de
gagner du terrain sur le virus et
d'éviter un éventuel reconfirme en
souhait principal du gouvernement et ses
opérations d'évacuations sanitaires vont
se poursuivre dans la semaine et monte
en puissance à raison de 6 et bixi
d'évacuation par moyens aéroportés par
jour et puis en fin de semaine
l'opération plus massive avec les tgv
médicalisé qui vont permettre de
transférer plusieurs dizaines de malades
vers des régions qui sont aujourd'hui
moins sous pression dans leurs services
hospitaliers et leur service de
réanimation une logique de transfert qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité dans le corps
médical s'est complètement inadapté on
prend des risques
les passions sont avec beaucoup de
matériel des tuyaux dans tous les sens
le rapport bénéfice risque de ces
transferts aujourd'hui n'est pas au
rendez vous il vaudrait mieux rouvrir
des lits pour retarder une mise sous
cloche des régions les plus en tension
le gouvernement table aussi sur
l'accélération des campagnes de
vaccination près de 5 millions de
personnes ont reçu une première dose de
vaccin ce qui représente 7 24% de la
population et seulement 3 29% des
français ont reçu les deux doses
nécessaires depuis le 11 mars
les pompiers ont été mobilisés pour
participer de cet effort et l'expérience
des centres de vaccination de grande
ampleur ouvert les week-ends est appelée
à se renouveler